[Music]
thank thank you very much Hadley today
I'm gonna talk about free and open
source software for data science the
lens I'm gonna use to talk about it
is kind of the how and why of our studio
a little bit about how the company got
started and where our mission of
creating free and open source software
sort of derives from but then I want to
get into the ways that tools both open
source and proprietary for scientific
and technical computing are developed
how how are they financially supported
how are they sustained how can you come
to trust them and get into a little bit
about the nature of corporations as
stewards of this sort of software and
I'll ask the question our corporation's
kind of inherently sketchy as stewards
of this sort of software spoil there
they are so then I want to talk a little
bit about what we can do about that so
I'll start by a little background about
how the company got started and so you
can get a flavor for kind of where I'm
where I was coming from starting the
company the seeds of the company go all
the way back to 1983 how many people
here have heard of Bill James people
have heard of Bill James okay so Bill
James was a math teacher in Kansas City
and back in 1983 I was a avid follower
of baseball and I absorbed all of the
you know analysis about baseball from
writers and sports casters and players
and coaches and experts and I came to
believe a lot of things I was hearing
about kind of how people how baseball
teams win games how you assess the value
of players and strategies so a bill
James did interestingly you can see back
in 1977 his first baseball abstract was
this little pamphlet he went from that
pamphlet over ten years to a New York
Times best-selling book where he used
data empirical data analysis to
systematically debunk many of the
assumptions that people had about
how baseball works and for me as a 14
year old that was really striking that
all these people who were you know who
had spent their lives in the game of
baseball who had developed kind of
conclusions and intuitions about how it
worked that all that could be debunked
by systematically using data it was
shocking to me and that stuck with me
when I went to college I didn't go to
college for baseball studies I went to
college for political science and when
you talk about political science you get
into public policy and public policy
decisions are made that affect the
well-being of many many hundreds of
millions of people and so the same thing
occurred to me that we've got lots of
experts and we've got lots of people
who've been absorbed in different fields
and observing phenomena for years making
these decisions and possibly probably as
it turned out not actually using data to
inform those decisions and as I've
become part of the art community I've
realized that the same phenomena repeats
and feels like medicine and business
that people are making highly
consequential decisions and they're not
availing themselves of the tools they
have to really understand how the world
works so this then kind of to me and
through college struck me as kind of the
fundamental problem to solve and it
seemed to me that software was an
important part of the answer this is
some of the software that I that I used
in college and graduate school and say
what you might about some of the
software it I had the experience of
software providing leverage so I could
my mind and and what I could absorb was
amplified by the fact that I could use
the software to better understand things
so from there I went to graduate school
at the University Wisconsin Madison and
studying political science and this is
gonna be an aside that this group I
think will find interesting it's not
really in the main thread of the talk
but I worked on a study there that was
studying the effectiveness of vouchers
and public school performance in
Milwaukee Milwaukee was one of the first
if not the first cities to implement a
school voucher program and there was a
study going on at Madison that was going
to assess how effective school vouchers
and I worked on that study so at the
same time there was a group at Harvard
that was very convinced that the
conclusions that would be drawn by the
folks at Madison were going to be wrong
so they were very keen to to credit
reproduce and criticise the results of
the study so we had so they asked from
the data and they said could we please
have the data so we can so we can do our
own analysis so we have the data in
paradox databases that were machine
readable super easy to send to them but
what we did instead true story was we
printed out all the data and ship them
crates of paper so that they could
re-enter the data on their own so that's
it's kind of where we were and
reproducibility and academia back back
then so that's a true story
so anyway anyway so when I got to
Madison I was really excited about data
analysis and computation and I was kind
of like could I kind of specialize in
software for data analysis and
unfortunately in political science at
that time software was definitely not
something you could specialize in and
and at Madison even data analysis was
kind of barely something you could
specialize in so I was kind of in the
wrong place so while I was trying to
when I was supposed to be doing my
graduate school work I was like teaching
myself how to program in C++ and
teaching myself how to program the Mac
and that inevitably led shortly to me
dropping out of the program and saying I
want to be a software engineer and what
I eluded to this little before what
fascinated me so much about being a
software engineer is summed up well by
this quote from Steve Jobs where he says
what a computer is to me it's the most
remarkable tool that we've ever come up
with it's the equivalent of a bicycle
for our minds and the other thing he
cites in that when he when he recounted
that quote was there was a Scientific
American study that looked at this sort
of efficiency of different modalities of
motion sort of the cost of transport
calories per gram per per kilometer as
it relates to body weight so he looked
at you know organisms salmon or
super-efficient horses were super
efficient they looked at different
modalities of human transportation and
they found that a person on a bicycle
was by far the most efficient
and that's I think what computers are
and what software is so that became my
fascination and I started I want to
become a software engineer and I wanted
to build software tools so I did that
for quite a number of years I built
programming tools I built research tools
about some writing tools and the
software I worked on was had a couple of
characteristics one was it was
proprietary software too as I was
working in start-up companies and
proprietary software worked on and
sought and startup companies is almost
it has sort of the seeds of its deny
demise built in from the beginning
because startup companies are built to
be sold and usually when they're sold
they're just there in some form or
fashion kind of destroyed or warped and
and the proprietary software is often
very bound up in the fortunes and fate
of the companies that sponsor its
development so I really enjoyed working
on software tools but I found that
proprietary software and startups was
not something I wanted to do anymore
after that
so I was sort of searching for what what
would I like to do next and I I came to
the conclusion that one of things I
wanted was I wanted to build tools that
were durable that could outlast a given
company and I wanted to build tools that
were accessible to everyone that anyone
could use respective of cost and that
led me to the idea of working on open
source software so I knew I wanted to
work on open source software I knew that
I didn't want to do software startups
and I at that time I found out about our
it's kind of took me back to the the
work that I had done in data analysis
and as an undergrad and graduate school
and it took me not very I don't know how
long it took me it was definitely less
than 24 hours to conclude this is what I
want to work on at the time I felt like
there the maybe for the next 10 years
now I feel like for the rest of my
career so I I was very lucky to discover
are and it also felt to me like I could
offer something to the community because
I had worked on kind of programming
tools and tools to to make people more
productive with complex complex software
so I also didn't want to do a start-up
and I thought well you know this is fine
because I think one or two people could
actually make a significant contribution
we wouldn't
to have a startup we could just make a
contribution and so that's when I
started working on the our Studio IDE
and I worked on it initially by myself
and then Joe Chang who I'd worked with a
couple previous companies join me a few
months later and together we set out to
build the our Studio IDE and the general
mission was to try to make a
contribution to open source software
first statistical computing so I want to
now say you know why is free and open
source software for science and data
science so important at the time I was
focused on this idea of durability and
and and accessibility but as I've joined
the art community I've come to realize
there's lots of other good reasons to
prefer open source software for data
science so I want to get into a little
bit of that and I first want to make a
distinction between different senses of
the word free there's for free gratis
and there's with little or no
restriction Libre and both are relevant
obviously with open source software
famously Richard Stallman summarized the
difference and the nature of Libre as
think free is in free speech not free
beer we sometimes with free software
focus too much on the fact that the
software has no cost but the most
important thing is that it comes without
restrictions and they actually the GNU
summarizes kind of the four essential
freedoms of free and open source
software and they mostly have to do with
being able to do with the program what
you wish
including inspect it modify it create
your own derivative works from it and
the fact that you are not dependent upon
the original purveyor of the software to
continue using or evolving the software
so though that's actually for science
especially more important the fact that
it comes without cost is important
that's actually even more important so
what are some of the reasons why we want
to prefer free and open source software
well this I don't need to speak at any
length about this with this group but
it's worth reflecting on the fact that
if I use proprietary software to do
science or data science and someone else
wants to reproduce my results at the
best that person needs to buy a license
for the saw
for that I used but at worst in this
often happens
I can't even reproduce my own work in
the future because maybe the vendor has
who created the software is going out of
business or they've made older versions
of their products and accessible so long
term reproducibility is really only
assured by using free and open source
software I want to point out briefly
just how important the our community has
been in this movement toward
reproducibility there was an article
written in nature in 2012 making sort of
making this case and at the time they
cited there are two systems known to
enable the packaging of code data and
text at the time one of those two was
sweep which the art community actually
came up with in 2002 so we've been at
this for 18 years certainly longer than
any other programming language community
there's another consideration which
which is resiliency as I said before
software products and companies come and
go we don't want our research our
ability to reproduce the research tied
to the fate of a specific product or
vendor now a variation on this theme is
that software doesn't come and go it
actually stays and becomes really really
important to customers and then the
vendor decides oh I tuned 'ti for us to
you know dramatically raise prices and
extract more value from our customers so
notably the the four essential freedoms
that I talked about ensure that this
cannot happen with free software there's
a great example of this from the
database world where my sequel which is
a GPL open-source database was acquired
by Sun and then subsequently Sun was
acquired by Oracle so Oracle a
proprietary database vendor now owned
all the copyrights to my sequel and they
were gearing up to try to do all kinds
of things to try to exploit that
position and what the community even
though Oracle actually owned all the
copyrights for my sequel the community
took the code from my sequel forked it
and created a another product called
Maria DB and continued on with
development so only the fact that that
software was free and open source kind
of ultimately protected the community
from a vendor that was going to be
abusive and you know we can think in the
art community our studio and many other
vendors
provided offerings around our and you
know the vendor the commitments of
vendors can vary over time companies can
get acquired they can ship strategies if
as a user your your your primary
investment is an open source our code
that will run irrespective of any
vendors products then then you're
protected from that you have that
resiliency there's another piece which
is participation I think maybe ten or
fifteen years ago many people might have
believed well a proprietary software
vendor can kind of enumerate and account
for all the methods that are important
in a field and then provide that or a
lot of people believe that I think now
the explosion of innovation in
statistical methodology nobody believes
that that a single vendor could be the
filter that who decides what methods are
supported and available and easy to use
so the fact that we have an open source
ecosystem around our enables what you've
seen with cran where there's this huge
long tail of innovation there can be
many many different approaches to
analysis there can be innovation in
methods and it's all supported by the
software so participation is another
fundamental finally important thing and
finally what I talked about at the
beginning accessibility and data
literacy is becoming it's fundamentally
important for organizations it's also
fundamentally important for individuals
and open-source software allows everyone
to participate and use these tools again
without regard for a cost so let's talk
then a little more generally about how
these tools for you know not just data
science but tools for scientific and
technical computing get built both
proprietary tools and open-source tools
how they're built how they're funded
what the underlying kind of intz
structural incentives are looking at the
history of scientific and technical
computing companies these are leaders if
you don't recognize them by company name
you certainly recognize their product
SAS matlab mathematica and they actually
have some significant shared
characteristics all of them started in
academia by one or two people and
the first few years of the project was
it was only one or two people and then
eventually they sort of organically
spread within academia and then grew
into becoming companies all of these
companies I would say if you if you look
at their about page or read the writings
of their founders or or talks by their
founders they identify their principal
mission is to support research in
science not profit and consequently
these are all private companies none of
these are publicly traded they're all
closely held by the original group that
founded them and of course notably
they're all they all make proprietary
software and not open source software so
what's problematic about this kind of
mirrors what I said about what's good
about open source software we have
reproducibility problems accessibility
problems centralizing decision decisions
about what methods are supported and and
and there's also that risk of companies
that want to perpetuate themselves be
incentivized to kind of hold their
customers hostage so that's those are
some problems one really good thing
about these companies though is that
they actually have an economic engine
that they can use to fund development
and without some kind of an economic
engine oftentimes sufficient progress
isn't made the tools actually don't
reach the bar where people can use them
to solve all the problems so they have
some significant drawbacks but they have
that that benefit of having this
economic engine so now let's consider
open source tools for scientific and
type of computing the ones that the
people here are probably most hands-on
familiar with are the ones the R and
Python data science ecosystems but there
have been lots of tools before that
notably Sage math and Qian u octave and
these all have roots quite similar to
the proprietary software vendors they
started in academia they grew very
slowly and organically at the beginning
and the founders of these projects also
were concerned principally with
supporting research in science and they
wanted to protect the software their
means of protecting it was to make an
open-source because at the time a lot of
these projects emerged the idea of open
source had gained more currency the
viability of open source had more
currency Linux had had achieved some
success
this is the approach that these these
projects have taken and so what's
problematic here is do these projects
have enough funding to sustain momentum
and yet where users want them to be and
honestly over half of software
engineering is solving boring problems
and sometimes you just need to have the
size of team and a commitment of a team
to go and solve those difficult and
boring problems so you know getting
enough resources as a say in these
projects can be a challenge and there's
also an issue of sort of project
organization are these projects cohesive
enough to deliver the software that
users need and then significantly our
organizations who are making decisions
about taking big long-term dependencies
on software projects are they
comfortable adopting the software
without visibility into the long-term
health of the project will the project
be around so there's different ways that
people have come up with to fund
open-source development there's grants
and Jupiter has actually done quite a
bit with with grants there's probably a
natural limit to how much funding you
can get from grants but but Jupiter's
done quite well with that you could open
source software can be funded by
companies that have an interest in the
software and Linux is the best success
story here where lots of really large
companies that had an interest in having
a free robust free UNIX operating system
all contributed to it and that's the
initial model for Ursa Labs working on
Apache era where there's a bunch of
companies including our studio that have
invested in building the software
because we think it's going to benefit
our users there's also the the
traditional method of venture capital
but you know if you look at those
companies I talked about mathworks
SAS Wolfram you know they've been around
that the evolution of their products and
the adoption their products took like 30
or 40 years they've been around for a
long time that's not really the venture
capital model is much much shorter so I
don't I don't think it fits particularly
well with with with building open-source
tools for science so the question is are
any of these do any of these models
actually work and this question was
asked rather or answered rather poignant
Lee or pointedly by
gentlemen from Wolfram because
apparently Wolfram gets asked all the
time why isn't Mathematica open-source
and so he wrote a blog post 12 reasons
why it's not open source and I'm not
gonna read these reasons out loud to you
if you take a quick scan of them I think
you get a sense for what the what the
reasons are and I would say generally I
agree with this analysis to the extent
that I do believe that you do you have
to assemble a group that works together
to achieve a set of shared goals over a
sustained period of time you have to
have strong technical leadership to
solve hard problems and you do need a
financial engine that can compensate
talented people to work on these
problems that's kind of the main gist of
his case I agree that those things are
required but I actually think it's
possible to do it with open-source
software and I think that the kind of
history of our studio demonstrates that
so if you look a little bit at the
history of the company 2008 late 2008 s
I believe when we started it was as I
said before just one or two or three
people working on open source software
and then about seven years ago we
decided that we were we thought we could
do a lot more with with just having
three people working on open source
software was fine but we thought there
was potential to do a lot more and so we
made a decision at that time to build a
company around the open source work we
had done with the the notion that we
could fund lots more open source
development if we had a company
producing revenue to fund the
development so we did that and you can
see over the last seven years or so
we've produced a huge amount of open
source software we have I think over 250
open source projects that we that we are
active developers on and we have this
set of commercial products that we sell
and we've grown from that original one
or two or three six people to now over
150 people
our company is profitable so the the we
are able to take the revenue from our
commercial products and fund it back
into feed it back into open source
development and then continue as the
company grows to grow that commitment
over time so I think we've figured out a
model by which
we can still produce open-source
software but do it in this kind of
sustainable well-funded way we sometimes
refer to this as a virtuous cycle where
we create open source software and lots
and lots of people because accessible
lots and lots of people use it and when
lots and lots of people use software
what happens is large organizations
start to adopt the software and larger
organizations typically have deployment
and management and scalability
requirements that are different than
individuals or small groups and that
creates an opportunity for us to build
products to solve those problems which
then gives us revenue to invest back in
open-source tools now you'll you'll
notice here it's pretty subtle on this
slide there's a line between these
things and you might ask the question
well where's that line and what's
where's the assurance that a company
like our studio as I said corporations
are inherently sketchy isn't gonna move
that line at some point let me give you
the operative principle that that for us
that's behind that line the operative
principle has to do with preserving
those four freedoms so the core
libraries packages protocols file
formats even productivity tools like our
Studio IDE need to be open source so
that users who adopt the software
experience the benefits of those four
freedoms and essentially or not or not
though the work is not locked in to the
products of a given software vendor the
tools that we create to facilitate
adoption of our in large complex
environments those tools are commercial
those are tools that you know candidly
if we're not providing good value to
customers they can continue using our
continue using the tidy verse our
markdown shiny everything without those
tools so for us we have to continue to
offer a good value proposition our
customers can walk away and that's
because the core software preserves the
four freedoms so that's kind of where we
draw the line and how we think about
open source versus commercial so I think
we've managed to create a new kind of
scientific and technical computing
company I think we have those attributes
that the the gentleman from Warren
Wolfram cited which is that we have a
financial engine that we can work on
this in a sustained way for many years
and apply it adequate
sources we also like those companies
think it's critical that we remain
independent to pursue our mission but
we've managed to do this in a way where
the core software is open-source and we
don't have lock in the way their
software but and that is by design so
we're pleased with this but it begs the
question again I said about about
corporations and are we trustworthy and
I would say we're not at face value
trustworthy because in today's world
corporations and we get into this in a
little more detail in a minute they are
pure profit maximizers so there by
default you shouldn't trust corporations
I think the our community needs more
than we're a corporation that has acted
you know acted well in the past in order
to place their trust and the work that
we're doing and I think customers need
to trust that we're looking for a
relationship of mutual benefit and that
we're not going to exploit our position
as a software vendor in the future as
has happened with other proprietary
software companies in the past so we
need to build we need to make our
motivation as clear and transparent as
possible and we need to try to build
more real long-term trust and I think
some of that has to do with the nature
of corporations how corporations work
and how maybe corporations actually need
to evolve so I'm gonna go back this is a
little bit elemental but I think it's
not something that I had thought really
carefully and critically about until a
few years ago what actually is a
corporation why do they even exist and
and what a corporation is is actually a
it's a virtual person so it's it's
acting as a person legally a person but
it's actually it's constituted by a
group of people so why do we even have
corporations well what what did we do
before corporations before corporations
any business that existed was either
undertaken by an individual it may be a
partner partnership of individuals and
so the individuals were actually
personally liable for everything the
enterprise did and when a contract was
made between a business and another
party
it was actually a contract with the the
individual or the group of individuals
so when when someone left a company the
contracts actually had to be
renegotiated business was really is
really fundamentally person-to-person
and that meant that anything that a
business could accomplish was sort of
bounded by what one person's assets
could accomplish and what what liability
one person was was willing to uh to
accrue so as the Industrial Age
progressed this model sort of didn't
seem adequate and the first corporations
were actually formed by Royal Act the
East India Company being one of the most
significant examples of that and then as
government's realized that we needed
things like bridges railways banks
utilities we need to operate in a
different scale that individuals have
been able to operate at so they created
this instrument called a corporation
that they believed needed this sort of a
absolving of liability and additional
capital that the corporate model
provided for so if you think about them
the essential nature of a corporation it
said it's a is an institution that it's
actually created by governments and
created by government in order to
benefit the societies that govern that
was the original purpose of corporations
and this worked very well and served the
public benefit in many in many regards
but if you look at that second bullet
you know about without fear of personal
liability that actually is a recipe for
bad behavior and we've seen that play
out as well so what we have today with
corporations has worked well but I think
we're seeing it crack a little bit in
the contemporary world so if you think
about the legal theories of what the
primary purpose of a corporation is
there's actually two competing theories
one is stakeholder this is gotta be a
regional idea and the sort of the
original idea that I've been sort of
advocating for which is that the
corporation is created by the government
and therefore has a social function and
the directors and officers of
corporation should consider all the
stakeholders affected by the corporation
employees the environment the community
shareholders kind of looking at
everybody's interests when they make
decisions there's another theory which
is shareholder primacy and it's a pretty
it's a pretty raw
notion which is the purpose of a
corporation is to maximize value for
shareholders within the bounds of law
really narrow and sadly that is actually
the the legal theory that has won in
anglo-american legal systems shareholder
primacy is the law that we live under
currently there's been a couple
significant cases that that established
that in many cases that has sort of
built that up a couple of more
significant ones was in nineteen
nineteen Ford decided that they wanted
to produce less expensive products and
pay their employees more so they stopped
paying dividends to shareholders again
balancing that the needs of all
different constituencies and the
Michigan Supreme Court said that's not a
thing you're not allowed to do that your
purpose is to create profit for
shareholders . you can't do that another
case a little more contemporary revlon
was faced with an acquisition proposal
that actually the shareholders appeal to
the shareholders was a good deal for
them but the board felt that it was
going to not be a good deal for the
employees or the bondholders people who
actually held debt and so they tried to
block the acquisition and in this case
the Delaware Supreme Court rejected the
idea that they had the duty or even the
option to consider the interests of
stakeholders other than shareholders so
there's been a number of cases like that
and that's kind of where we stand with
with corporate law and many people find
this lacking it's you know companies
while they're pursuing profit can can
create lots and lots of public health
and environmental problems they can
create systemic risks as we saw with
recent financial crises it leads back to
the question is that we've given these
corporations a special legal status does
that carry any reciprocal obligation of
the public good and it's shouldn't
companies be able to consider the
welfare of their own employees and their
community when they make decisions a lot
of the bad behavior you see by
corporations is precisely because they
can't consider it legally can't consider
these things so in response to this a
bunch of states have actually adopted
legislation
that permit note permit not require
permit directors to consider things
other than shareholder value and now
we've seen recently this last year
there's this group called the Business
Roundtable that's composed of a bunch of
CEOs of mostly big public companies and
for the first time since 1997 they in a
public statement said that corporations
shouldn't exist solely to serve
shareholders so that's I think people
are sensing that this regime is wrong
this isn't really talking about
fundamentally changing the system this
is just more saying we have
dissatisfaction with the system so what
can be done to change this system so I
don't know how many of you who hear
heard of the company and one if people
heard of and one it's a basketball shoe
company and I think as it will turn out
this company will be very significant in
the history of corporate law and perhaps
of capitalism so let me tell you a
little bit about and one basketball shoe
company founded in 1993 they were a
socially responsible business they had
great they treated their employees
really well had great benefits they
allocated 5% of their profits to local
charities and significantly they their
shoe companies and they had overseas
factories they work to implement a
supplier code of conduct to make sure
that workers and overseas factories were
treated well safely had good wages etc
so they were sort of a socially
responsible business kind of before that
became something that more widely
practiced so what happened two and one
well they were pretty small in the mid
90s they took on external investors in
1999 and it turned out that they grew
quite a bit over that span from 95 to
2001 but then ultimately they had
competition from Nike and others and
their sales dropped and they were sort
of forced to sell the company and what
was really surprising and disturbing to
the founders was who created this
company with the idea we created the
company we control the company we want
to build a socially responsible business
when they went to sell the company it
was done exclusively to maximize
shareholder value and so after the sale
and they could do nothing about this
all those commitments to employees their
overseas workers and local community
were just stripped away so they were
shocked and disappointed and it made
them think something needs to change so
they got together with a friend of
theirs to start a nonprofit called b.lab
and the idea behind b.lab was to create
a new form of corporate governance so
they created the nonprofit and they
actually created a new corporate
structure called a benefit corporation
and this is a reaction to the
shareholder primacy regime where the
directors of the company are legally
required to account for all of the
stakeholders community employees in
their decisions it's a legal requirement
not an option and they also named a
public beneficial purpose as part of
their Charter that again they are
accountable to pursue legally
accountable to pursue I won't read this
in detail but you can see a little bit
of the actual legislation behind
Delaware public benefit corporations and
it puts a stringent legal require on the
directors to act in a different way and
to not use the shareholder privacy
regime so the this nonprofit has
actually been successful in getting 34
states to pass legislation that permit
benefit corporations there's currently
over 7,000 them these are some examples
you've probably heard of some of these
some of these companies and you might
not have known that they were a benefit
corporation in addition to these
companies there are some public company
so the line at the top are public
companies they're not benefit
corporations but they have wholly owned
subsidiaries that are in fact benefit
corporations so I think this benefit
corporation idea has the seeds of what
it takes to transform what corporations
are and how they relate to their to
their world into the communities and all
of their stakeholders and it kind of
takes this idea of good companies that
that has existed over the last 20 years
whether it be about you know Energy Star
compliance or Fairtrade organic food and
it elevates that to the idea of good
companies so most of you or many of you
can probably guess what the next slide
of this presentation is going to be I'm
really happy to announce today that we
are now a certified Delaware
benefit corporation
[Applause]
thank you
so we actually have a new a new name
we're no longer our studio Inc we're our
studio PBC and we've always tried to run
this the company this way that's always
been what we've tried to do but now it's
actually baked into our charter it's a
part of our corporate DNA it's it's a
rigid requirement not something that we
do at our discretion as part of it we
actually named a public benefit and that
actually goes into our Charter this is
our public benefit and you note that we
cite the creation of free and open
source software for data science
scientific research and technical
communication it's a little bit broader
than data science today we were just
data science but I'm optimistic that we
have created a model that actually is a
better model for scientific and
technical software so someday I think it
would be nice to do more within
scientific computing so that's why we
wrote the public benefit a little bit
more a little bit more broadly as part
of being a public benefit corporation we
actually will release an annual report
describing kind of how we've served our
public benefit beneficial purpose we've
posted the first of those reports on our
website a few highlights we talked a lot
we provide some metrics around kind of
our investment and open source projects
and I said before there's over 250 of
them there are we dedicate over half of
the company's engineering resources to
open source right now that's we have 36
full-time engineers that work on open
source software and that's broken down
kind of by project in the report and
there have been hundreds of millions of
downloads of our open source products
and packages so these are metrics were
going to keep reporting on every year so
in addition to being a benefit
corporation the B lab has actually
created a certification program that
both looks at whether you've changed
your charter but also looks at your
impact specifically on your workers
customers community and environment and
actually rates you across a bunch of
categories and so we're happy to also
share that we've been certified as a B
court by the B lab and there's a you can
see our impact report there actually
which actually has all those ratings is
also available
there's also available now so some of
this though begs the question it we've
become a B Corp and that reflects I
think who we are and what we're about
and what we aim to be but it also
doesn't necessarily
talk about the future and I want to tell
everyone here that our plan is to remain
an independent companies and to never
sell the company but you know yes so
that's that is what we're gonna do but
how can we actually make that happen how
can we provide assurance that's gonna
happen
we actually had we do have outside
investors as minority shareholders and
prior to this conversion we actually had
written into the financing documents I
had special rights that I could block LA
I would I say undesirable outcomes I
could individually block the sale of the
company but you know just saying that I
can block that the sale of the company
isn't really fully reassuring because
you know what if I die what if I change
my mind so it's a little over reliant on
one individual so we also along with the
transition made some changes to kind of
how those shares are held and how the
rights are exercised so now there's
actually a group of people all inside
the company who exercise those rights so
if I you know die or or change my mind
or anything like that we still have
those protections in place and before I
conclude I wanted to also talk about
kind of who ultimately benefits from our
studios success as I said in the talk
we've tried to build a company where we
have lots of beneficiaries all of our
stakeholder beneficiaries we do have
shareholders and the traditional way
that shareholders get r enumerated is
usually either selling the company or
going public so that is not a plan so
what we're gonna do is take our profits
and use those to purchase stock back
from our shareholders over time
so once we've met that commitment we are
going to dedicate a substantial portion
of our profits to philanthropic causes
that that that relate to our mission of
open source software and open science
and those donations we did we we've
documented in this year's annual report
the donations that we've made but as we
are able to purchase stock back from our
shareholders and dedicate more of our
profits to these donations will also
report specifically on that in our
annual public benefit report so thank
you all very much for helping us to
build this company and build this
commune
it's been an incredible experience far
exceeding anything I could have ever
hoped for and I'm excited for what the
future holds thank you
[Applause]